one of roberto dan's great inventions is
the light and heavy chest it was a chest
that a kid could lift
quite easily but a strong man when he
tried to lift it couldn't lift it in the
illusionist they took that idea that
same idea i'm going to reveal the method
of the light and heavy chest agq it's
david copperfield this is the breakdown
[Music]
first up now you see me
it's 11 50 p.m here in vegas that's 8 50
a.m in paris your bank opens in less
than 10 minutes one
two
three
a number of years ago a screenwriter
named ed reichardt came to my show and
we did the show in the round which was
very unusual hasn't been done before and
we did an illusion also quite
unique where we would
vanish me and a specter to vanish from
the theater and reappear uh in a
location in hawaii it was pretty amazing
groundbreaking and it's what inspired
the whole now you see me series
i like that little french guy
where'd he go
there he is
teleporting around the world wasn't ever
done in the magic show and they saw this
opportunity to use it in a movie the
magic wasn't just
card tricks or whatever it was something
that could be done as a whole
basis of real drama inside of your
helmet you should feel a button
don't press it just yet now that button
activates an air duct that connects
paris to las vegas okay good now you can
press it all right now that's it hold on
tight you might feel a bit of a vacuum
in our version i brought the reign back
with me
into the theater in the round
in this version
probably a little bit more
cool for the audience
the money comes back
to the theater you know
it's about credibility when i did this
illusion and people thought it was
ridiculous nobody's gonna believe it
people said it couldn't be done not
credible at all and we spent three years
interviewing audience members changing
bits little by little to make it a
credible thing and finally we got it so
the people in the audience were crying
so when ed reichert saw that uh in the
show he saw a pretty good version of our
thing so it could be credible it was
something you could do it does feel
credible in in this film
because they really are committed to it
and they did all the steps that we did
that we found we had to do to make it a
credible thing having proof having uh
kind of a relationship between the
monitor in the theater and um
yeah
i think it worked our version happened
over the heads of the audience it was a
surrounded in a circular theater i
wanted
you know people beneath the illusion
itself they had the in the round and i
guess because they didn't have people
below they had the the piece collapse up
so it was kind of avoiding the trapdoor
idea to me magic isn't about making
something disappear it's about really
having the audience feel emotionally
attached to it this is an example of
that because this was about characters
that
you care about these people i mean these
actors are amazing also the people in
the audience who are involved with this
are people that you get to know and care
about or have some kind of stakes in the
matter so it's not about the the
illusion it's about the illusion plus
caring about why it's happening the
prestige because making something
disappear isn't enough
you have to bring it
back
that's why every magic trick has a third
act
the hardest part
the part we call
the prestige
i love the poetry that chris and his
brother put into this movie we don't use
words and magic like the prestige or the
all the things he did but i think it's
kind of
nice gravitas that he added
many people say there's seven
pieces of magic seven effects and it's
hundred percent not true i'm
with my amazing staff invent new
technology all the time and i think in
this case uh what christopher nolan and
his brother did with all the electric
currents the tesla coil
effects he created a new language in
that way that doesn't exist in any magic
show in history so i think he had the
same kind of instinct as i do in my show
now you know i'm doing magic with
dinosaurs and spaceships and aliens and
time travel nothing that you could find
in a magic book most magicians you know
unfortunately kind of uh do things that
have been done before but a lot of the
really great people who are trying to
progress
the art form in the past and also today
are trying to change the language and
move things in a new way you know they
say in there that
if you vanish something you have to
bring it back
in that case a bird was vanished and
they had to make for the child
the the fear of something bad happening
to the bird
go away i don't believe it's important
to bring things back uh necessarily i
vanished an airplane once
and i didn't bring it back
and it was viral before viral existed
and it's because i didn't bring it back
it was kind of unsatisfying the audience
was going what happened to it if i
brought it back it would have closed the
circle i don't agree with that idea that
you have to bring it back
now you see me too
ninja
[Music]
[Music]
my executive producer chris kenner
started a whole trend of juggling cards
in a beautiful way and it was called
cardistry this sequence is based on that
entire idea
andre geek who took that idea and took
it to another level helped design the
sequence which is pretty interesting
all these moves are based on real moves
real things you can do
everything you're seeing here really
could be done
it'd be kind of hard to do it all in
that sequence but they are all possible
to do they helped a little bit with a
little bit of a camera technique to get
it to work perfectly each time
but
all very risky moves there could
actually be really happening
this whole throwing of cards started a
whole trend youtube videos of people
trying to do hard throwing where they
land in specific spots we did
200 takes to get this one shot in movies
you know
we all do
uh many many takes of
scenes as as actors in this case this is
a lot of things put together john chu
who is a wonderful director of this film
his background is in dance and
choreographing beautiful sequences so
the combination of cardistry and john
choo's direction comes together quite
nicely here
this is very advanced sleight of hand to
make that all work in a real world
situation it would be very risky to do i
was once held up at gunpoint
and i stupidly
uh did what is magic called the pocket
dodge i showed my pockets empty even
though my passport's never in the pocket
that's a real world situation i did but
in fact i think in retrospect is pretty
pretty stupid to do and here uh they're
on a movie set so it's okay all these
little details are are based on real
things and that's what's really uh
rewarding for me all the sleight of hand
moments are really uh based on real
palming
back palming sleeve manipulation
techniques of elastic all that's real
stuff you know and they put it into kind
of a nice sequence i think
my friend levent simkindly vanishes a
jumbo card on stage with that exact
method on the back of the card is a a
pattern of his jacket and he just
vanishes it and it's really looks great
and then as a gag he kind of reveals it
and shows what happens so it's okay for
me to say the story but it's a really
great thing and it does work there's a
magnet in the jacket and it sticks to it
when my friend does it the card vanishes
and it looks fantastic and then it's
really magnetized to his coat the famous
magicians of the past used to scale
cards into the audience take cards with
a picture on it and throw them in the
audience and hit certain marks
in the theater amazingly it was a great
skill and this is uh
taking that to another level it's using
it for real purpose they would skip
cards off the ground like a rock and a
lake and all this is based on that
[Music]
[Music]
there's also a pickpocket technique
where you're managing people to move a
certain way you can pick their pocket
here you can touch them they're going to
look this way you can steal their watch
it's that kind of technique all combined
in this in this piece the illusionist
i borrow a handkerchief from someone
you madam
thank you using audiences personal
artifacts has always been part of magic
even the street performer would use
things from the audience i think it
makes the audience feel they're part of
it and involved also makes it more
impossible when you're using one of
their objects in the real version of
this it was a ring
and a handkerchief that would vanish and
reappear time
from the moment we enter this life we
are in the flow of it
we measure it and we mark it
we cannot defy it
we cannot even speed it up or slow it
down
they did something really nice here
in magic you know there's manipulation
of all kinds cigarette manipulation
which is a no-go end right now
but that was a thing you know
manipulation of coins and cards and
billiard balls billy balls will appear
between your fingers
all that
and i think in the illusions they did
something kind of cool to make the
oranges small enough to do actual
billiard ball moves i think that was a
really good idea when the orange goes up
or goes in slow motion
we can do that they did it with special
effects but as long as it can be done it
has a lot of credibility for me ed
norton's character really was a
wonderful magician a lot of skill i know
ed norton worked very very hard in his
technique one of the illusions he did
was the orange tree which is based on
something i have actually i have the
original one
created by robert hudan in in the 1840s
it was the big rage of the time real
oranges would appear they'd be tossed
out into the audience and they were real
oranges
people would freak out
in this movie it's done
in a very very high level it didn't work
quite like that in reality in the
original hudan version the leaves would
already be there and the oranges and the
orange blossoms would
grow slowly but this is starting from
the very beginning where it's kind of a
combination of
a growing orange tree and a blooming
orange tree it really combined two
different effects which are all legit
to make it happen roberto dan was a
clock maker and an automaton maker so
basically the orange tree was an
automaton mechanical leaves would reveal
oranges like an automaton the flowers
would appear and
atom of time-like butterflies would
allow the butterflies to fly
from behind the bush and reveal the
handkerchief and rain might i see it one
of roberto dan's great inventions is the
light and heavy chest it was a chest
that a kid could lift
quite easily but a strong man when he
tried to lift it couldn't lift it that
illusion
in the story goes that stopped a war in
france we're dealing with a group called
the marabons the french sent in their
most powerful wizard robert hudan showed
the french magic was stronger than this
faction that was going to go to war with
the french so this one box this one
illusion helped solve a war as the story
goes in the illusions they took that
idea that same idea i'm going to reveal
the method of the light and heavy chest
back then people didn't know about
electromagnetism turning power on and
off to make a box electromagnetically
stick to the ground was a whole new
thing and in this case
they're kind of replicating that same
idea make it stand up straight like that
wouldn't work quite with that technique
but they combined that to make this
kind of a
a credible challenge
and i think it works pretty well
the great magician
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty cool stuff i really enjoy the
sleight of hand
i think he could have
just
done this
little origami thing and left it like it
is i've never seen that before i love
that idea
i'm a new dog lover so this is a
kind of cool and that could work you
know it wouldn't look exactly like that
but that really could work
[Music]
i want something better than them
his technique is really nice his
movement is very beautiful all the magic
isn't real all of it's a lot of it's not
really happening but
it's kind of it kind of could it follows
that rule that you know if it could be
done could you do that and the answer is
yes you could make that happen
and besides these women are very happy
this is kind of like street magic in a
elegant setting let's put it that way
[Music]
what i like about it is they didn't just
take the easy way out like like
bewitched which i love by the way
where they would just blank out the
thing would just disappear boom
they took the time to
do technique where it was
credible
maybe it did happen maybe the sleight of
hand could have existed so they went the
extra mile to make that happen
this is a real effect
that my friend channing pollock did a
version
of this looks a little bit different but
the production of a glass is normally a
wine glass filled with wine but he does
it
you know where
it's about jewelry for the women
as you all know a magician is nothing
without his that's funny he says a
magician is nothing without props well
he just did a whole bunch of slide of
hands so that makes no sense at all
take it
[Music]
vanishing bullets would be sleight of
hand it couldn't work exactly like this
but it could work for sure they are
replicating all sleight of hand if
confetti couldn't come from the gun
obviously it was borrowed gun so it
would have to come
from somewhere else in his uh this
person and he could do it it's pretty
risky pointing a gun at some
mustache dude there's nothing in here
that couldn't be done it wouldn't look
exactly the same but my favorite thing
is is the dog bone for sure i think
that's that feels really new
the incredible bert wonderstone
[Music]
foreign
in bert wonderstone our team created a
sequence for the movie that
the actors could feel really proud to do
because there's no cuts nothing changes
and they work really hard and when we
got the take
everyone was really happy
so this piece you can watch over and
over again you can slow motion it you
can look at every frame and from right
here there's no cuts covers themselves
up watch the other hand
it's not going to cut away
focus on that hand for a second keep
your eye on that hand he gets covered
puts his head underneath the thing
hand's still showing
see his form still there no cuts
all brightly lit the background is
brightly there's no darkness there's no
black area behind
you see everything around it one shot
this big crane technocrane shot
that can show that one of the joys is to
put magic in a film
that
could really happen and really does
happen for real in camera
[Applause]
arrested development
i used to dance a lot in my show with
fluffy shirts
and gigantic movements
and large objects
we actually made a boat appear in the
bermuda triangle
he makes it vanish in this case with a
little bit dancing
definitely i think i'm to blame for this
i wish i could do the split though that
was pretty good there was
a book when i was a kid written by al
jaffe called the mad book of magic
and it was all these you know how to
put your finger over here in two
sections well you'd cut your finger off
that was the method for it it was just
crazy methods that would really
inflict major pain on yourself to make
it happen it's all a very big parody
this is an example of that will arnett
is great and he does spectacular magic
his method was kind of like the al jaffe
book of magic where the the the method
destroys the family's boat
michael magician never reveals is i sunk
it i sent the yacht
at least i think i sunk it i mean i blew
it up and i don't see it anywhere
it's a method
probably could have worked and finally
houdini
this was the big time
the stunt that would finally put me over
the top
[Music]
let me try it now
boss
you just performed three shows your b
tomorrow i'll get the boys will set it
up
right now
all right
one would never do something for the
first time you're always going to really
have planned what your
what your escape route is how to get out
of the situation so adrian brody went to
tannen's magic camp he loved magic as a
kid and really studied it so it's kind
of fitting that he got this part besides
he's just kind of a genius actor
[Music]
something's wrong whoa whoa homer hurry
up get him out
hurry up
it's stuck
hey
harry houdini discovered that escaping
from things
really captivated audiences interest you
know start with handcuffs
and kind of upped the game straight
jacket escape underwater escapes he
found that had a connection with people
people got that and the idea of
having
near death
as your adversary was one that people
could really understand and relate to
i've done a lot of escapes from an
imploding building i did a water tank
escape i got hurt in the water tank
escape there is danger to it in
houdini's day everything happened behind
a curtain
except for a stray jacket escape which
you could show people everything else
was hidden behind things and in those
days you can get away with that people
would sit patiently for an hour watching
a
red curtain and not knowing what's
happening behind today they'd walk out
you know but in those days you could do
that
this sequence is the water torture cell
which we have who needs actual water
churches right here in this museum so
that's all very legit
you know but when this is done normally
once you're submerged in the tank you'd
be hidden from view
the audience would not see the process
of escaping and in today's world you
have to see the process luckily in
movies you get to see the process and
this is a failure situation
which
never happened to houdini glass never
broke they never had to break the glass
to get houdini out all the historians
will tell you that that happened in the
tony curtis movie in this movie but it
never took place
there's another way to get out way
easier way to get out if you had to be
in this trouble they just hoist them out
of there historically not accurate but
looks pretty good thank you so much for
watching all those clips with me hope
you learned something until next time